hey everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I've got another news
story to share with you and this is a
featured article from science news org
about a jellyfish cousin so that's a
type of cnidarian that may survive
without working mitochondria which is a
pretty big deal to say for a
multicellular eukaryotes
so basically what's going on here is
we've got this multicellular eukaryotes
remember eukaryote means that they have
membrane bound organelles typically that
includes a mitochondria this would be a
first to find one that is a eukaryotic
cell without working mitochondria and
it's multicellular so multiple cells
make up this parasite and so it's called
Hennig ooh yes alma Nicola and it's a
parasite so it's not a free living
eukaryote it has a parasitic life cycle
it goes back and forth in its life cycle
between salmon and worms so it has
different parts of its life cycle that
it completes in each of those hosts it
needs needs to be able to parasitize
both of those hosts in order to complete
its life cycle and it's really
noteworthy because this would be the
first example of a multicellular
eukaryotes it has gotten rid of its
mitochondrial genome so it has no
working mitochondria it still has some
mitochondria like structures that can be
seen with a microscope but they aren't
carrying out aerobic respiration most
likely because they don't have a genome
so if you need kind of a reminder
mitochondria are the organelles and
eukaryotes that produce ATP so they
break down carbohydrates glucose
primarily and break it down and it's a
complex process called aerobic
respiration but the gist of it is that
it makes ATP which is the cellular
current energy currencies like the the
molecule that's used for easy energy in
the cell I have a link to a video on
aerobic respiration that I filmed a
while ago and I'll put that in the video
description if you want to see more
about what that aerobic respiration
process entails but as for this news
article which will also have a link in
the video description I might say well
why is this important it's really cool
because
about two billion years ago is when
eukaryotes got their start there was an
ancestor of all eukaryotic cells when
were eukaryotes includes all plants all
animals all fungi lots of unicellular
and multicellular eukaryotes and so the
ancestor of all of these different
organisms engulfed a bacterium and sort
of embarked on this mutually beneficial
or mutualistic relationship where the
ancestral eukaryotic cell engulfed this
other bacterium it provided this
bacterium with sort of energy and
protection and a place to hang out and
this bacterium was capable of aerobic
respiration and provided lots of energy
to the cell that engulfed death and so
over a very long period of time this
mutualistic sort of symbiosis eventually
resulted in this evolution to
mitochondria inside a eukaryotic cell
and so the mitochondria like
chloroplasts which is another type of
organelle and photosynthetic organisms
it has its own genome and that's because
it has descended from this bacterium
that was engulfed about two billion
years ago and so it's a genome is
separate from the organisms DNA and this
is so separate from the organisms DNA
that's housed inside the nucleus of that
organism so you guys are mitochondrial
genome that's in the mitochondria and so
there are a few single-celled or
unicellular eukaryotes that have gotten
rid of their mitochondrial genome but
this would be the first example of a
multicellular eukaryotes that's done the
same thing so you might be asking what
happened to that mitochondrial genome
and why well remember because it's a
parasite it is living and reproducing
inside these worms and salmon and so the
thought is that it can rely on its hosts
not just for shelter but also for energy
so we can just take the ATP that's being
used by the worm and the salmon
in order to complete its reproduction
and other sort of metabolic and means
and so this would have allowed it to
shed this cumbersome mitochondrial DNA
the reason I say it's cumbersome is
because every single time a cell divides
it has to replicate its DNA before it
can divide and that includes both the
nuclear DNA and the mitochondrial DNA
and it takes time and it takes energy
and it takes materials to be able to do
that so if a cell gets rid of its
mitochondrial genome like all of the DNA
in the mitochondria it just doesn't have
to take the time and the energy and the
resources to replicate that anymore and
so it looks like an ancestor of this
parasitic nidaria cnidarian rumor is tha
the phylum of animals that includes
jellyfish coral sea anemones so it falls
into that group that's why the article
calls it a cousin of jellyfish so this
parasitic cnidarian because it just
begun relying on its hosts for all of
its energy it's gotten rid of this
mitochondrial genome it stopped stopped
replicating it however many generations
ago I don't think it's been established
maybe yet how long it's been without its
mitochondrial genome but that has
probably helped it to save energy help
it to save time it can replicate a
little bit faster and therefore maybe
give it a leg up over competing you know
other competing species and so this is
just really cool this is the first time
we've ever had a multicellular animal
that does not have a mitochondrial cell
sorry does not have a mitochondrion and
it's in itself and I also have another
video that I'll put in the video
description on the endosymbiotic theory
this is a major biological concept it's
sort of broadly accepted this idea that
a an ancestral eukaryote engulfed a
bacterium that eventually evolved into
mitochondria and then one of the
descendants of that original ancestral
eukaryote also engulfed another
bacterium that eventually became the
chloroplast and that's where we get the
photosynthetic lineages
so plants and photosynthetic
photosynthetic algae and so forth so if
you're interested in learning more about
the endosymbiotic theory I'll have a
video about that
as well I think that is it for today let
me know what you think about the news
story and what you think about some of
these topics with the endosymbiotic
theory aerobic respiration evolution of
animals I think they're all really
interesting and I'd like to know what
you have to say so that's it for today
and thanks for watching bye